Tim Tebow here.
Everyone thinks I want a contract, but without one, I've done so much this year.
Nervous father's to Mike!
Wide 20 in motion!
Is that Tim Tebow?
Wide 80 breathe, hut hut!
Without a contract,...
There he is.
...I've tackled the unknown,...
...worked on my delivery...
I mean, talk about illegal use of the hands, right?
...and improved my mental game.
If I had a contract, could I do this?
Gotcha.
If I had a contract, I couldn't do my own stunts.
Or save these puppies.
If I had a contract,...
...I wouldn't be with all you fine people tonight.
You might wanna hold on to those doughnuts.
I've accomplished so much.
Even fulfilled a childhood dream.
Bottom line, contracts hold you back.
Am I right, Iceland?
You know what I'm talking about.
Switch to T-Mobile and we'll buy you out of yours.
A little help?